let's talk about the Paris climate
agreement according to two sources with
direct knowledge of the decision Donald
Trump has indeed made the decision to
pull the United States out of the u.s.
climate agreement now they need to
figure out sort of the logistics of how
to withdraw there's a couple of options
one is to initiate a full formal
withdrawal which could actually take up
to three years to complete the other
option is for the United States to exit
the underlying United Nations climate
change treaty which would be faster but
more extreme according to a report just
from an hour ago from Axios this is huge
and if for no other reason then that
this is actually a way that Donald Trump
could undo President Obama's legacy and
it is a more direct path we've talked
about lots of the executive actions
which have been symbolic they're not
actually representative of changes to
policy they are sort of indicative of
changes in terms of the attitude of the
White House this would actually first of
all pull the u.s. out of a significant
climate agreement but it would also send
a major signal to the world and to the
other countries that are part of the
Paris climate agreement that the United
States is not committed to being a part
of the solution to the climate crisis
and it could lead to other countries
bailing as well not necessarily because
other countries don't want to be part of
the solution to the climate crisis but
because other countries particularly
smaller countries could say rightly so
we're tiny if the u.s. is not going to
participate why should we do anything
that would cause us to adapt or adjust
the sort of day to day energy
consumption and impact our citizens if
our impact on world climate change is so
tiny because we're a little country if
the US isn't even going to be party to
these to this there are only two other
countries that aren't supporting this
deal they are Nicaragua and Syria
not exactly the countries that you would
imagine the US wants to throw in with
and say hey this is the group that is
doing the right thing on
climate it's Nicaragua and Syria and the
United States of America the u.s. does
not have its you know what together
that's the message that is sent by
Donald Trump pulling the u.s. out of the
private Paris climate agreement and it
reminds me of the United Nations
Convention on the Rights of the Child
which has now been ratified by every
country except for the United States of
America what can other countries do in
response to this if they want to sort of
I don't know if punishes the right word
but push back against the United States
they can do quite a bit and I've been
very clear that trade wars are usually
not good for anybody but other countries
can put tariffs on US goods for example
and by the way in this context it's
important to note that while the
majority of Americans believe that
climate change is real roughly 79 80 %
we still have about half of Americans
who do not believe that climate change
is caused by humans so Donald Trump is
on the one hand building anti-american
sentiment by pulling the u.s. out of the
Paris climate agreement but he is also
reinforcing the non scientific beliefs
of roughly half of Americans that humans
are impacting the climate and this is
why people were concerned about Trump's
decision-making ability every day we
read news about how China and India are
making significant investments regarding
climate change and the u.s. reaction is
to pull out of the Paris climate
agreement now which allies of the US
will be happy about this is the EU going
to say wow we're really glad that the
United States is no longer going to be
part of this agreement is Canada going
to say hey you know what our alliance
with the u.s. is strengthened because
Donald Trump has pulled out of the Paris
climate agreement no and in the air that
making coalition's and allies should be
a top priority in foreign policy Donald
Trump is doing so much to create one of
biggest anti-us coalitions ever and
what's most disturbing to me about that
is that there are trumpets who like that
there are trumpets who love the
nationalistic approach of Trump and they
see other countries frustration with the
United States and with trunk as a good
thing the really important question for
us to start keeping track of is when the
presidency is over how long will it take
to recover from the ridiculous decisions
that Donald Trump is making and more
importantly the repercussions of those
decisions today's program is made
possible in part by WNYC s on the media
on the media is a way to maintain a
level of frankness and transparency
about the media that we consume you can
listen to on the media which is WNYC s
weekly investigation into how media
shapes our worldview if you like the
David Pakman show my guess is you would
enjoy WNYC S on the media Brooke
Gladstone and Bob Garfield are your
hosts on a search for the truth in the
24-hour news cycle you can catch them on
their weekly podcast on the media on
Apple podcasts Google Play stitcher
Spotify or wherever you get your
podcasts